the raiders were back at home this
afternoon trying to improve their
impressive 2020 resume
standing in their way was an old rocky
mountain rival john treach has our
highlights
john that's right for all of its
promotional glimmer and glamour las
vegas can be a cruel place to an
unprepared and careless visitor
today's testimony comes from denver 53
bronco players made their maiden voyage
to the desert and the palace
and left feeling beaten john gruden and
josh jacobs two men earning their
paychecks in 2020
for the raiders first drive of the game
that man josh jacobs
asserting alpha dog dominance over the
rival touchdown
in just two years he has ripped the
broncos apart second quarter broncos
trying to take the lead
just before half but just he takes the
ball
away from the broncos and quarterback
drew locks second pick of the game
second half
josh jacobs mostly fishing game of the
year 21 carries 112 yards as you can see
he was really unbothered by
the denver defense 26 lead drew lock
continues to ride the struggle bus
intercepted by defensive lineman carl
nassif locke was
actually the key to las vegas success
four interceptions
fourth quarter how about devonte booker
booker party for six the former bronco
joins the
raiders rodeo in las vegas and scores
twice raiders win by widest margin of
the year 37-12 and remain
perfect in the division now kevin martin
has seen everyone in the fc west this
year but the only team with a 3-0 record
is las vegas she joins us now from
the home of the victorious raiders good
evening kevin
well good evening john yeah the raiders
picked up their third straight win today
their
second straight against afc west
opponents and defensively this might
have been the most complete game we've
seen this unit play all season as you
mentioned
forcing five turnovers four
interceptions in one fumble recovery
and offensively it was all about the
ground game devonte booker picking up
two touchdowns and then second year
running back josh jacobs putting on a
show
112 yards on the ground two touchdowns
derek carr also averaging
or adding 150 yards in the air he talked
about the versatility of this raiders
offense
yeah again we've won games where we've
you know
ran it a whole bunch and didn't go for
it much and we've had to
win games and shootouts and the cool
thing about that is is we can do it both
ways which in this league you have to be
able to do both
and if we can get turnovers the way that
we did today on defense
uh that that will bode well for us in
the future that will bode well for us
uh going forward and winning more one
more games and and making a run at what
we really want to do
the raiders have now beat each afc west
opponent
once as you mentioned john they are now
3-0 in the division
their next chance to play someone coming
up next sunday
who the division leading chiefs what a
time to get on a roll that's going to be
a huge one i know they have that one
circled for now reporting live at
allegion stadium kevin martin 8 sports
now